freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute mit kevin nachdem wir
vor mittlerweile fast einem monat noch
länger her gemeinsamen tag verbracht
haben und ich für kevin gekocht habe
kennen sagt profikoch also die küche
habe ich gedacht wir lassen nicht mal
jemand anderes kochen und zwar zufällig
es gibt 69 verschiedene kategorien mir
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 69 48 okay
leute ich hoffe ist es was leckeres
kuchen warst hast kategorie kuchen yoga
und wir kriegen aber ein kuchen
geliefert jetzt wird aber es kann
natürlich immer sein dass das restaurant
als bisher kuchen anbietet und
zusätzlich halt noch ganz viele andere
sachen ja gut also schon gute tradition
aber gegen so leckeren kuchen kann man
jetzt auch nicht so eingängig wollte
auch schon sehr lecker gekocht wird
können skandal mit 2 1 die videos
gedreht ich weiß nicht welche davon in
schon online schaut einfach mal bei
kevin ska vorbei
das ist natürlich ganz oben verlinkten
der beschreibung aber wir gucken jetzt
erst mal 15 kuchen bekommen wo oben vor
drauf hätte erklärte dazu sagt es und
ich meine da gibt es auch herzhafte kost
also wir müssen natürlich trotzdem ins
zu fall entscheiden bekommen
starbucks top top donuts dunkin donuts
paul bonatz pizzeria ok kraft wobei die
pizzeria strauß liefert erst in wobei
das ja ich die nehmen wir auch mal mit
also quasi wie viele verschiedene lehrer
jetzt sechs verschiedene land davon sind
alleine drei download stores soll man
denkt oh ja jetzt gibt es ein leckeres
mittagessen und dann kriegst du einfach
13 uhr parkplatz in die massen
na gut sagt mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und
6 dieser crêpes laden aber er ist
richtig gut dass erst richtig gut
bewertet wenn wir mal drauf gehen ja ich
habe also nachspeisen französisch kuchen
für mich klingt eigentlich ganz gut aber
was haben die noch im angebot beliebt
berichtet nutella kräften
fleisch käse blattspinat und mega light
also ich find's lustig aber das ist so
ein herzhafter crêpes business guide
okay bekommen wir die kategorien
beliebte gerichte tier immer nicht mit
kreditkarte kreft 123 44 verschiedene
kategorien haas und der bisher ist alles
offensichtlich kuchen
sie sollten wir nicht versuchen es gibt
aber nur platt und rottet fragt warum
warum war das in der kategorie es gibt
hier verschiedene übrigen nicht sagen du
suchst dir erstmal eine kategorie und
dann anschließend im crap aus als wenn
du mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 4 1 geld
taten etwas das heißt eigentlich bdk das
ist auch von der universal begriff ja
ich würde sagt normal müsste zu
schreiben herzhaft ja ok
das würde man fester versteht darf also
wir haben hier verschiedenste
variationen krebs rzb hat vielleicht nie
drohen meist zwiebeln chili sauce
aktuell schafskäse oliven pepperoni
frischer kluger eigentlich schon geil
aber auf dem track hast du schon mal
sogar schon tatsächlich ja ist tipps
haben takko aber es hat so ein bisschen
so geht es in die richtung weist auch
ein bisschen weicher aber es kann schon
lecker bestimmt einmal ein bisschen
vorbei aber wir probieren das ganze mal
auf den ausgang ok wir zählen erst mal
wie viel es gibt 20 verschiedene krebs
gibt also nenne mir eine zahl zwischen 1
und 20 10 die goldene mitte
ich bin gespannt was ich glaube es gibt
unter den zwanzig auch bestimmt welche
die nicht so krass lecker sind aber du
musst jetzt bestellen und essen was
kommt red
geld hat vielleicht brokkoli creme
fraiche konsole frischer knoblauch finde
ich klingt schon ist okay hast du schon
mal glück gehabt also ja 14 euro führen
kündigt ist auch schon amtlich
stattlicher gut du hast das los gezogen
jetzt bin ich dran sagt mir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 4 3
okay ich hatte kurz angst dass es bisher
weil daraufhin mit der bericht wäre
etwas richtiges essen 123 veganisch gibt
es drei stück okay finde ich eigentlich
okay weil meine freundin macht gerade
die challenge und ernährt sich sechs
wochen begangen da hab ich das alles
auch noch mal jetzt auch schon mit die
gerne gekocht gegessen ich finde es
eigentlich ganz meisters aber zur
abwechslung mal zu machen gibt nur drei
stück kichererbsen curry soja hat würde
ich das bin ich gerne essen also ich
hier die zweite sagt mir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 3 als ob sie das so yakin
die bunt wie billy soße wichtig für mich
die soße und meist ich bin sehr gespannt
kevin ich glaube ich glück habe wäre ich
muss sagen heute mal guten tag oder fünf
von fünf sterne restaurant beim
zufälligen bestellen habe ich glaube ich
noch nie also ich bestelle und wir sehen
uns bleibt also leute hier ist die
packung angekommen
das was dort eigene typen das ist auch
schon mal hab ich schon weil sonst die
partei nicht jeder indifferenten und wo
was sind erst dann bitte für größer
deiner warme satz nochmal für unsere
politik jetzt mache auch johanna ist
sieht geil aus
hier ist meiner mehrere keine ahnung wie
man es ausspricht und ich mache auch mal
auf der wied hat genau so aus das sind
halt beides krebs sondern aber meiner
läuft nicht so aus aber wir haben auf
jeden fall eine gleich große portion
vier jahre nicht kurz sorge dass du
deutlich mehr zu essen bekommt seinen
teller und es ist glaube ich nicht ja
wir haben recht ordentliche portion
bekommen zum glück ich glaube wir haben
wirklich ein gutes los gezogen hat er in
diesem format das ein oder andere mal
echt hält also ich hatte schon richtig
scheiß sachen und richtig kleine damit
hatte ich nie was durchschnittlich ist
also dementsprechend ist das echt gut
ich möchte hier mal eine ecke an und da
bin ich sehr gespannt weil das zog
freigibt labor ja dann nehmen wir mal
die erste garde oder jetzt das so jagd
auf jeden fall finde ich auch richtig
war was das ist kann sich jetzt schon
liebe die schreibenden chili hin und die
meinen augen für die das ist nicht so
dieses ding von wegen wir schreiben hier
und da hast du den hauch einer ahnung
von schärfe ist wenn da ist wirklich die
mutig sondern us wirtschaft lebt ja aber
dafür dass das vegan ist also das
schmeckt so heftig die textur ist so
heftig nach an hackfleisch also mal dass
auch sensationell beschreibt macht er
zum einen hat austoben dem cap
logischerweise das hackfleisch der
gewonnen 2000 soll ebenso verarbeitet
was hat eine super super schöne cremige
konsistenz im ganzen
den gibt's obendrauf oder ist mit
trainer der ist tatsächlich christfest
also das wirklich idente wird der
italiener sagen also wirklich super
gegart ist das eine sensation erklärt
vorherigen kraft einfach denn ich glaube
die allermeisten zuschauer haben
wahrscheinlich wird nie einen herzhaften
crêpes gegessen zu haben oder ist das
komisch dass ich das noch mit wenn ich
also nicht so gängig ist überhaupt nicht
gegenstand aber dann auch mit der
qualität ja tatsächlich wirklich sehr
sehr gut tun uns mal eine zweite
position zu stärken können wir am
anderen ende haben beide jeweils ein
ende in ruhe gelassen sagen wir lieber
hat wer ist sie probiere ich mal wo wir
waren am anderen ende und jetzt bin ich
gespannt wie der kontrast zu echten
markt wert ist weiß man das wirklich die
du bist du bist kein quatsch erzählt was
es geht also ich habe man kann schon
doch durch also das sehr sehr saftig die
burkas oder so kommt wirklich sehr gut
durch aber auch nicht sogar ganz so las
ich kenne strand sondern so angenehm
darf nicht angenehm aber ich muss
wirklich sagen dass veganer alternative
heftig sensationell möglich es ist
wirklich sehr gut gut da im vergleich zu
dem ist jetzt ein bisschen trockener
was jetzt aber wenn du den so ist bin
ich aber gar nicht mal schlimm aber gut
wegen der wand oder so selbst ich würde
aber sagen ich finde sogar mein dich in
deiner und du findest du ein bisschen
geld tatsächlich also wir haben werden
beide mit unseren krebs und super los
gezogen deswegen würde ich zum studieren
und dann doch wieder oder gar nicht
wieder zu sagen absolut mücke habe über
kuchen zu verkaufen
wirklich groß ist möglich freue mich
darauf mich jetzt auch zu essen
danke dass ihr wieder zugeschaut habe
und mir ist möglich geld mit essen zu
bedienen eingeleitet
ja das ist er bekäme vorbei
[Applaus]